[Musique]
mick haller
mais plus de chocapic mais pourquoi pas
une figurine nutella pendant tout y est
[Musique]
voilà c'est possible qu'est ce que tu
fous de tes journées je peux pas tout le
temps derrière toi
tu vas tu poses comme une malade pour
faire des choses que personne ne voit
les moins tu crois que ça m'amuse
doivent pas voir grandir les enfants et
comme on jouerait qu'on échange que tu
comprennes d'accord je prends ta place
tu prends la mienne au hockey dis moi ce
que je peux faire
thorn et louise c'est leur tour dentiste
demain 11 heures quand c'est pas
possible
jr et c'est bon
ce sont là des chats
lentement sûrement oui je sais j'ai ouï
oui j'arrive juste là
[Musique]
t'as pas l'impression de l'avoir oublié
quelque part [ __ ] écoute attend c'est
d'accord que j'accepte
en résumé nous avons donc échange
effectif de vos fonctions pendant un an
heureux de démarrer une nouvelle vie je
vais enfin pouvoir proposer un peu
tant côté maintenant c'est l'autre
j'ai réécrit la voiture
[Musique]
pareil
j'ai l'intention de tenir une stricte
égalité entre deux sexes mini cars
y'a pas de chocapic non je suis pile
entre les sourcils pour faire moins
sévère pour les enfants si on leur
explique et comprennent alors je préfère
vous divorcez